welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka how erotic and
Tiger King is the craziest show that
Netflix has ever made we follow Tiger
king Joe exotic who is a mullet having
gay polygamist reality TV star country
singing voice of an angel having
presidential candidate that used to be
the manager and owner of GW Zoo Joe was
married to two men at the same time both
of which turned out to be straight and
one who accidentally shot himself whilst
playing with a gun he did have he didn't
have beautiful balls though hashtag
squad goals with Joe they work at the
zoo which specialises in big cats such
as lions tigers and bears oh my not that
last one and here they used to feed the
animals with meat from a Walmart bin and
live in caravans owned by Joe Joe paid
very little so they couldn't really
leave it wasn't all bad though as some
of the staff were literally giving an
arm and a leg to work there so I'm sure
that they all had a job that they can
look back on and cry Joe started making
a name for himself and slowly rivalry
started with another zoo called the big
cat rescue were run by Caroll Baskin
this is Carol Baskin this is her current
husband and this isn't even the top 10
weirdest things in the show not me
proudest one Carol was married to a man
named Don Lewis that went missing after
signing over all of his belongings to
Carol and pretty much leaving a paper
trail that said Carol murdered me
Carol started trying to bring Joe down
and eventually the two and head2head
leading to a bigger mystery then who is
a host in Westworld I'm gonna tell my
kids that this is the man in black it
really is an absolutely crazy premise to
start the show off with and when you sat
six hours into this documentary you're
so used to things being absolutely
mental that you don't even realize this
guy with more teeth than brain cells has
been sat with his shirt off the entire
time
Tiger King is one of those shows that
comes along once in a blue moon and it
reminds you why it's not a good idea for
cousins to date it really is one of the
weirdest things I've ever watched and it
ensures that I'll never be canceling my
Netflix subscription again now in the
backdrop of the show whilst all this is
going on Joe is in the midst of filming
a reality TV show and it's at this point
that I think the real Joe whoever that
may be
gets taken over by an evil entity known
as the tiger King the tiger King is like
the part of your brain that comes out on
a Friday night after you've had a couple
of drinks you know the one where you
don't give a crap about anything anymore
and start texting that girl you met four
years ago in a bar saying that you would
spend 10 years in isolation just to be
in the same room that she once farted in
yep
that guy so that guy takes over Joe and
slowly he starts to obsess over Carol
much in the same way that she starts to
obsess over him now if I was gonna
choose a nemesis it would definitely be
a woman that I believe got away with
murder
Tiger king and Carol go head-to-head for
many years and eventually Tiger King
ends up copying her to try and gain more
views to his stuff and he calls his
company Big Cat Rescue Entertainment
that reminds me yeah make sure you
follow my second channel new rock stars
entertainment Carol doesn't like this
and rightly so because she had to
literally kill to set this company up
and she sends the lawyers after him
which leads the character I mean King
being sued for $1,000,000 realizing he's
in a lot of trouble tiger King puts
everything in his mother's name so that
she ends up getting the debt and going
bankrupt I mean well I was wondering
what to get my mother for Mother's Day
so I might as well hand in new rock
stars entertainment over to her
enjoy enjoy the lawsuit tiger King
realizes that he's probably said a lot
of stupid stuff on camera but luckily
for him the shed with all of the footage
in it burns up in a mysterious explosion
he was out of town when all this went on
though and he's not the type of guy that
would pay someone to do anything bad so
it definitely wasn't him so he shows up
in the air and he's getting sued for a
hefty amount of YouTube views luckily
though along comes on next character
I mean person Jeff Lowe a millionaire
that strangled his first wife for a
mistress that would end up becoming his
second wife Jeff and his wife were
swingers that entice beautiful women
into their hotel rooms with pictures of
Tigers
that's the sound of a million people
photoshopping a curb into their profile
picture jeff is living proof that money
really does buy happiness and he becomes
friends with Joe even offering to bail
him out of the trouble that he's in with
Carol now there's a lot of things that
go on in between all of this but the
most important thing to learn is if your
wife is pregnant
and you need a babysitter then you want
to get one that's not too bad to look at
Jeff ends are pretty much managing the
zoo himself and because he's the one
with the money it's not too long before
the tiger King ends up doing everything
that he says including handing the zoo
over to him now we don't know if this
next bit definitely happened or not but
it is thought that Jeff and Co ended up
realizing that there was a bike lane
that Carol used to ride along beside a
sanctuary now I'm not saying that this
is what happened but allegedly they
decided that one day she might be riding
along that and if someone was
accidentally sitting at the end of it
with their gun and that went off well
accidents do happen
I mean look at how I was conceived so
there's a plot to kill Carol and tag I
didn't even mention the biggest part at
this point Joe is running for governor
of Oklahoma in the hopes of being
president one day
now count yourself lucky America because
if this documentary had a read in 2016
then this is the guy that you would have
ended up with instead you got someone
totally but never mind the Oklahoma
sexual it doesn't eventually end up in a
position of power but the federal
government do end up spying on him so I
guess I guess he is with the government
in some way anyway Joe tries to hire one
of Jeff's friends to kill Carol but
instead he takes the money travels out
to where she lives and parties like
they've just made it legal to marry a
sister so we pretty much have a smoking
gun a paper trail that ties everything
back to Joe who isn't going to live
happily ever after with his new husband
looking at Joe right now this got this
guy had three husbands that aren't Ewing
gay and I've cut a corn even get a text
back anyway Jeff and Coe throw Joe under
the bus and he's sent to jail he still
maintains that it was Jeff that did it
but we don't know for definite now Jeff
did get another business partner that
fell out with him and the show ends with
the notion that there may be a federal
investigation going against
Tim I hope not though because his nanny
needs good references for when I have a
baby but where is everyone now well Jo
was sentenced to 22 years in prison this
January this was because of the
murder-for-hire plot against Carol
Baskin but it's not all bad as car EB
recently started GoFundMe to help him
win his freedom yay jo has filed a 94
million dollar lawsuit against the
government and he also wishes to receive
a presidential pardon I wouldn't hold
your breath though I don't even think
the guy can spell his own name Carroll
itself is publicly stated that she's
very angry with how the documentary has
come across as she initially thought it
would be an exposure of Gio's
mistreatment of animals and exploiting
big cats for nefarious purposes she says
that it's been transformed into a
sensational story line to draw viewers
in and that a husband's bones are buried
in the way I mean she didn't catch she
didn't kill her husband she just wants
to make that clear Carol's new husband
stuck up for her and said that in the 15
years they've been married they haven't
had an argument and Carol told him to
say that I'm just kidding Carol I love
you I don't think you did it Finn who
was at one point Jo's husband has had
his teeth fixed so at least someone
ended up happy Rick Kirkham who was
originally the brain behind Joe show
walked away from it a better man and now
lives in Norway with his wife as for
Jeff how low can you go he and his wife
Lauren are still setting up their zoo
which they plan to open this year but of
course due to lock downs at the moment
this may be pushed back they now live
with their nanny who has become part of
the family and I've gotta get me a
million dollars somehow overall everyone
is living there hashtag best life and if
you're one of the people who decided to
watch this video without actually seen
the show itself then I highly recommend
that you check it out it's difficult to
put into words just how bonkers it is
but if 2020 could be summed up in a
person it would definitely be Joe exotic
he'll make you laugh he'll make you cry
his friends will make you go to the
dentist more and overall I feel like a
better person for watching it if you
stuck in lockdown then you definitely
need to check this out because it
reminds us hey it could be worse this
could be happening which prayin ever
does because god damn overall Tiger King
is incredible
it's perfect its Citizen Kane level
parasite level the greatest documentary
of our times and that's why it gets a 10
out of 10 yeah maybe that is a bit too
much I mean this guy did talk about how
his husband used to put his balls in his
face at his funeral and anyway obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on Tiger
King if you enjoyed it or if you binge
through it too quickly and now have
nothing to watch for the next 5 years of
self-isolation comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of Westworld
season 3 episode 3 which is gonna be
linked at the end we go over the big
theories in the show so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more if you want to support the channel
from as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it mister thank
you you get access to content early you
want to come chat us after the show
either follow us at definition whitey or
click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people I subscribe
to the channel and this month he can win
the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set and
all you have to do is comment on a video
and make sure you serve with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of April and the set
will be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
Definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]